hey everybody i'm david oaken with IBM
cloud and today we're gonna talk about
helm helm is a package manager for
kubernetes that makes it easy to take
applications and services that are
highly repeatable or get used in a lot
of different scenarios and it makes it
easier to deploy them to a typical
kubernetes cluster to really understand
and take that home let's walk through a
typical scenario of a couple of
different applications and services as
they're deployed in kubernetes so let's
say we're working with an e-commerce
application that's signing up users for
a certain shopping platform for the
holidays I'm sure you can think of a
couple examples there and let's say that
we've written a node.js application that
we're going to deploy to our kubernetes
cluster here we're going to say that
that's marked here with one deployment
but we have two replicas of this this is
because this is going to need to be
highly available so we have two replicas
to handle all the different requests
that are beginning to be coming in and
then additionally underneath this we've
got a MongoDB database this is going to
handle communications to and from each
of our replicas just our de manger no
js' application that we have and let's
say that we've also written a service as
a way to access our application and
let's say we've written that as a node
port node port meaning that there's just
a one to one ratio between IPS inside of
an outside of our kubernetes cluster so
in order to deploy this kind of
application stack you need to define
this or one way that you can define this
with kubernetes is writing a couple of
yellow files to describe what your
deployments are going to look like what
your service is going to look like etc
and this is a fairly parse down example
but let's go through some of the key
elements of this here with our
deployment of our nodejs application
let's assume Mungo's therefore you know
persistence sake
with our deployments we know that we're
going to be writing an image of node and
so for example our UML file here
might look something like node
and you might say version one something
like that and again for the number of
replicas that we have for this
application we know that we need two
replicas here to again be able to handle
that high availability now for our
service again we decided that it was
going to be a
type of node ports so we're gonna write
that here and again this is a one-to-one
ratio between IPS outside of our service
and inside of it to be able to route it
to just one service here on our
deployment because we have two replicas
here to mitigate load whenever it comes
to our deployment and then let's say for
this particular example this is going to
be served up on port 8080 so we can
write that purely inside our service
that um will file here now this all
works and let's say that you wrote this
application yourself you wrote these mo
files yourself you're really familiar
with the configuration so as long as
you're still working on this it's fairly
easy to be able to make changes to it
and change things as requirements might
change so let's say the holidays end and
you want to go ahead and spend this down
you know exactly where to find the
number of replicas that you need to
change but let's say you move on to a
different job in your company and
somebody else is stuck managing this
they might not know even in this simple
example where to go to change the number
of replicas that you have with this
particular application so what if there
was an easier way to manage the
configuration for your whole application
stack and separate that logically from
everything you have with your particular
templated application this is one place
where helm can really help you out think
of home is combining two particular
components for your whole application
stack a configuration which is going to
be defined by our values that yellow
file up here and a template or what we
call in helm a chart your chart is going
to consist of all the files that you're
going to be templating here now how do
we actually template these files and
inject variables in its them well you're
going to take your configuration and
you're going to instead use templating
language to decide where those values
are going to be put inside your
templates or your chart here so let's
say we want the number of replicas to be
determined by our configuration up here
instead of hard-coding that into our
particular deployment that llamó file
the way we could change that is we could
say replicas are instead gonna be
managed by values dot deployment dot
replicas I'll shorten it but you
understand you just write out for that
so that way this is gonna say okay we're
gonna refer to the values deployment
replicas node and sure enough that's
much easier to find in our configuration
so we can simply write to here now this
means that depending on what you want a
hard code in your template you can
decide what does it keep that hard-coded
here or you can make another change here
and simply refer to the same thing
instead you would say image and then you
could say something like node 1 so
you could do the same thing for your
service as well let's say you want to go
from using a node port to a load
balancer as given to you by kubernetes
in the future so that you could instead
change this and you could say values dot
service dot type and you can change this
to say values dot service dot port this
means that for a developer on this
project or for somebody who's working
infrastructure and making sure that this
is deployed fresh you can simply have
them change your configuration here so
for example here we're just gonna write
node port and for this we'll just choose
8080 now how does this actually work and
how does this get all of this combined
into your kubernetes cluster
well the command that you're gonna write
when you install the helm CLI on your
machine if you want to combine this into
one charm you would simply write helm
install something like my app if you're
referring to the right folder that you
have as the CLI tells you to do and what
helm will do is it will actually take
the templating chart that you have look
for particular parts where you've
defined variables in your configuration
and it will go to that configuration
file use the ml to find the nodes that
you need and inject those parameters
inside your templating file once it's
got everything comprised helm will send
this over to a component that needs to
be installed on your kubernetes cluster
called tiller think of tiller is
basically just
server-side component of helm it's gonna
take the commands you've sent with the
helm client and turn that into something
that your kubernetes cluster will
understand so that it will say okay take
the service map that there take the
deployment map that there and take this
database not that there now this becomes
extra useful when you want to do things
like upgrade to a new configuration and
rollback let's say you're past the
holidays and you say okay we can spin
this down to where we only need one
replicas now this particular deployment
so rather than taking down the
application whole meal and then go ahead
and you know redeploying it with the new
configuration you could simply in say
and type helm upgrade my app so you
could said replace upgrade with install
or replace installed with upgrade and
that's how you can use that same syntax
that way what you would do is helm would
again template everything out make sure
that it works the way you want it to and
get that configuration sent over to
kubernetes so it can manage uptime as
being the most important characteristic
of your particular stack let's say you
made a mistake when you're upgrading it
and something that you just changed it
to doesn't work the way to roll that
back you guessed it is the roll back
command this what helm will also give
you is it actually keeps a version
history for you of different
configurations that you've sent over the
wire with helm so that you can roll back
to the last known working configuration
whenever you want to lastly when you're
working with these you've talked about
hey maybe you moved on to a different
team but maybe other teams need this
exact same kind of configuration as well
well you can make use of repos as well
and you can actually deploy your charts
into that repo by typing helm package
and then using helm repo index to send
that up to a repository so anyone in
your company can make use of the same
chart as well so what we've discussed is
basically taking a typical scenario
going through it in a fairly
understandable way by hard coding your
llamo but by parameterizing it with helm
you just make it a little bit easier to
manage these packages and upgrade them
when you need to and make it easier for
everyone else on your team to understand
it as well it's currently in the
incubation phase of the cloud native
computing foundation and it's ready for
open source and ready for you to use
today thank you
if you have questions please drop us a
line below if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe and don't forget you
can always get started on the cloud at
no cost by signing up for a free IBM
cloud account